seguramente has escuchado el concepto de
números pares e impares y lo que vamos a
hacer en este vídeo es pensar en
funciones pares o impares y como veremos
existe una cierta semejanza entre los
dos conceptos y también algunas
diferencias primero pensemos que es una
función par una forma de pensar una
función par es que si la giramos sobre
el eje de la función se ve igual el
clásico ejemplo de una función par es
este la parábola clásica donde tu
vértice está en el eje y esta es una
función para esta es la gráfica de la
función
efe de equis igual a equis cuadrada
observa si la giramos sobre el eje y
obtenemos la misma gráfica para decir
esto de una forma matemática y ya hemos
hablado de esto cuando hablamos de la
idea de reflexión para decir que una
función es igual a su reflexión sobre el
eje
decimos que fx es igual a efe de menos x
porque si reemplazas las x con menos x
entonces giras la función sobre tu eje
quien ahora que hay de una función impar
bueno una función impar si la giramos
sobre el eje y y después sobre el eje x
al final la función se ve exactamente
igual déjame dibujar el ejemplo clásico
de una función impar el ejemplo clásico
es fx igual a equis ubicar la cual se
dibuja de esta forma
observa si primero gira sobre el eje y
obtendrás esta función que estoy
dibujando con una línea punteada si
después giramos esta función punteada
sobre el eje x vamos a obtener de nuevo
la misma función
ahora como escribimos esto de una forma
matemática bueno esto quiere decir que
nuestra función es equivalente no sólo a
una reflexión sobre el eje ya que como
ya sabemos es f
equis sino que además tenemos una
reflexión sobre el eje x que es el
negativo de esto es decir esto que estoy
escribiendo es hacer dos reflexiones de
seguro algunos de ustedes están viendo
un patrón o estarán a punto de ver un
patrón que conecta las palabras par e
impar con los conceptos que conocemos
anteriormente en nuestras vivencias
matemáticas te acabo de mostrar una
función par cuyo exponente es un número
par
y te acabo de mostrar una función impar
cuyo exponente es un número impar del
cargo que intentes con más polinomios y
que cambies los exponentes pero resulta
que si sólo tienes una función
efe de x igual a equis a la n entonces
será una función para sí en españa y
será una función impar si n es impar
esta es la forma de relacionar ambos
conceptos ahora seguramente muchos de
ustedes están pensando que hay muchas
funciones que no son par ni impar y s de
hecho es el caso por ejemplo si tenemos
la función x cuadrada + 2 esta función
que tenemos aquí sigue siendo para ya
que si giras la función mantienes
simetría sobre el eje y regresa a ella
misma pero si pensamos en x menos 2 esto
elevado al cuadrado x 2
plaza la parábola hacia la derecha y ya
no es una función par porque observa si
giramos sobre el eje ya no vamos a
obtener la misma función así que no es
sólo el exponente además importa la
estructura completa de la función pero
si tenemos una función tan simple como x
a la n vamos a tener una función par o
impar dependiendo del exponente de
manera similar si desplazamos esta
función no será más una función en par
por ejemplo si estás trabajando con la
función x kubica + 3 ya no es una
función impar porque si gira sobre el
eje que llegarás por acá y después al
girar la sobre el eje x obtendrás algo
así por lo tanto no regresamos de nuevo
a la función original
ahora te tengo una pregunta interesante
puedes pensar en una función que sea
simultáneamente par en par' existirá una
función que cumpla que fx sea igual a fm
equis y que a su vez cumpla que fx sea
igual a menos
efe tm x pausa el vídeo y piénsalo un
poco
bueno te daré la respuesta piensa que fx
sea igual a la constante cero esta
función es la recta horizontal y igual a
cero está que tengo aquí y si gira sobre
el eje y obtienes la misma gráfica y
seguirá sobre el eje x de nuevo obtienen
la misma gráfica así que fx igual a cero
es par e impar un caso muy interesante